welcome everyone it's my pleasure to
welcome you to what by my count is the
39th Lee page lecture series these
lectures started 49 years ago to honor
the memory of Professor Lee page who was
a professor in this department the
physics department from 1916 until his
death in 1952 today it's my great
pleasure to be introducing to you John
press kil who's the Richard Fineman
professor of theoretical physics at Cal
Tech John got his PhD at Harvard under
Steven Weinberg and his career is noted
for an amazing breadth of activity and
that started even back then when he was
working on both Technicolor alternatives
to what we would call now the standard
model of particle physics and also a a
cosmological production of monopoles a
problem that was eventually solved by
inflation his work in particle physics
cosmology and gravitation led him in the
early 90s to be working on quantum black
holes and interesting problems
associated with quantum information in
that system and that that theme of
quantum information has been as marked
as work since that time in 2000 John
became the founding the fun of the fount
he founded the the Caltech Institute for
quantum information that's now an NSF
frontier center and it's now referred to
as the Institute for quantum information
and matter and he's the director of that
Institute if you've looked at the titles
of his three talks you'll know that he
has a wide breadth of expertise and and
will be able to enjoy that through these
three talks it'll also be our pleasure
to enjoy his clear lecturing that's been
rewarded twice by the Associated
Students of Caltech Teaching Award so
please help me welcome John Prescott
well thank you very much Paul and
excited to be here at Yale one of the
world's great centers for quantum
computing research and quite honored and
humbled to be the lead agent is
expressive information technologies
today but we also know that those
technologies are going to be surpassed
in the future by new technologies that
we can't really expect to imagine today
it's interesting just the same to
speculate about future technologies I'm
not the ideal person to do that I'm not
an engineer I'm a theoretical physicist
and not really all that knowledgeable
about how today's computers really work
but as a physicist I know that the
crowning intellectual achievement of the
20th century was the development of
quantum theory and it's natural to
wonder how the development of quantum
theory in the twentieth century is going
to impact 21st century technology
quantum theory by now is rather all the
subject but some of the ways in which
quantum systems differ from classical
systems we've come to appreciate only
relatively recently a lot of those
differences have to do with the
properties of information encoded in
physical systems to a fittest this
information is something that we can
encode and store in some physical system
like the pages of a book but
fundamentally all physical systems
really are quantum systems governed by
quantum mechanics so information is
something that we encode and store in a
quantum state and physicists have
recognized for a long time that
information carried by quantum systems
has counterintuitive properties that's
why we like to speak about the weirdness
of quantum theory and we cherish and
take pride in that weirdness but we can
also ask whether it's possible to put
the weirdness to work
to exploit unusual properties of quantum
information to perform tasks that
wouldn't be possible if this were a less
weird classical world and that desire to
put weirdness to work is driving the
emergence of a field that we call
quantum information science which gets a
lot of its intellectual vitality from
three main ideas quantum entanglement
quantum computing and quantum error
correction and in this talk I'll try to
explain these ideas I'd like to start at
the beginning you know that any amount
of classical information can be
expressed in terms of indivisible units
of information bits and we can think of
a bit as an object like a ball which
could be either one of two colors and I
can take a bit and I can store it inside
a box and then later on when I open the
box the color ball that I put in comes
out again so I can recover the bit and
read it in quantum information
information carried by quantum systems
two can be expressed in terms of
indivisible units what we call qubits or
quantum bits and for many purposes it's
useful to envision a qubit as an object
stored inside a box but where now we can
open the box through either one of two
complementary doors those doors
corresponding to the different ways in
which we could prepare or observe the
state of the qubit and I can put
information into a qubit through door
number one or door number two and later
on when I open the same door the color
that I put in comes out again I can read
the bit just as though it were classical
but on the other hand if you put
information into a qubit through door
number one and then open door number two
then even though we know exactly how the
qubit was prepared we can't predict what
we'll find
we'll see either a red or a green ball
each with probability one hand so that
means that in order to read the quantum
information you have to do it the right
way or you'll damage the information and
you can appreciate one consequence
that if you think about copying quantum
information suppose I had a quantum copy
machine what would that mean it would
mean that if I had put information into
a qubit through door number one then I
could make a copy of the qubit and open
door number one on the original and the
copy and the color that I put in would
come out of both doors on the other hand
if I had put information into door
number two and made a copy then I could
open door number two of the original and
the duplicate and the color I put in
would come out of both boxes but in fact
there's no such physically possible
machine we can't copy an unknown qubit
and the reason is that the copier has to
probe inside the box to make the copy
and if it guesses correctly the door
that I use then it would be able to copy
the ball just as though it were
classical what if it guesses wrong and
opens the wrong door then it will damage
the information and there won't be any
way to build a high fidelity copy so we
might be able to clone a sheep but we
can't clone a qubit now as you've seen I
like to think about qubits in kind of an
abstract way that's often useful but
qubits can have many possible physical
realizations and I'll mention a few
others later but if you'd like something
to come concrete to think about you
could imagine a single photon a particle
of light which has a polarization it's
electric field say can be oriented
either horizontally or vertically
corresponding to the two states that we
can see when we open door number one on
the box on the other hand we can
consider polarizations along the 45
degree rotated axis corresponding to
door number 2 so I could make for
example a horizontally polarized photon
and then measure the polarization along
the Tilted axes and I wouldn't be able
to predict what I'd find it would be one
polarization or the other each with
probability 1/2 now the really
interesting differences between
classical and quantum information can be
appreciated only I want to consider
systems with more than one Cuba
so let's suppose we had two qubits they
could be far apart from one another one
at Caltech in Pasadena the other and the
custody of my friend and the Andromeda
galaxy and some time ago these two
qubits were both on earth and they
interacted establishing a correlation
between the qubits with some interesting
properties namely for this particular
state of the two qubits I can open my
box through door number one or door
number two and either way I just find a
random value with probability one half
of being red or being green and the same
thing is true from my friend in
Andromeda he can open door number one or
door number two and either way just
finds a random bit so neither one of us
by opening the box acquires information
about the state of the box and that's
kind of peculiar because with two qubits
we should be able to store two bits of
information where is that information
hiding in this case well the answer is
that all the information is actually
encoded in the correlations between what
happens when you open a box and
pasadenian and a box in Andromeda
because it turns out for this particular
state of the two qubits I can open door
number one or door number two and I see
a random bit but if my friend opens the
same door on his box he'll see the same
thing that I saw so if we both open door
number one won't be fine could be red or
could be green but it's guaranteed to be
the same for both of us and the same
thing if we both open door number two
and we know this is true because we've
tried the experiment a million times
with identically prepared pairs of
qubits and it always works this way now
there are four distinguishable ways in
which a qubit in Pasadena could be
correlated with the qubit in Andromeda
we could see the same color or different
colors when we both open door number one
or when we both open door number two and
by choosing one of those four ways we've
encoded two bits of information in the
two boxes but what's unusual is that
that information is inaccessible locally
it's stored entirely in the correlations
and I can't acquire it and pass it
or my friend and Andromeda and that
property of quantum information that it
can be shared by two distantly separated
parts of a systems what we call quantum
entanglement and it's the really
important way in which quantum
information is different than classical
information correlations themselves are
not unusual we encounter them all the
time and daily life my socks are
typically in the same color so when you
look at my right foot and observe the
color you know what color sock to expect
when you look at my left foot and you
might think it's pretty much the same
thing with the boxes if I want to know
what my friend will see when he opens
door number one and Andromeda I can open
door number one in Pasadena to find out
I want to know what he'll see when he
opens door number two I can open door
number two in Pasadena to find out so
aren't the boxes just like the socks is
know they're really fundamentally
different and the essence of the
difference is they're just one way to
look at a sock but we have these two
complimentary ways of viewing a qubit
and that makes the correlations among
qubits much richer and more interesting
than correlations among this this
phenomenon of quantum entanglement
strange correlations between parts of a
quantum system was first explicitly
discussed in a paper by Einstein and
collaborators over 80 years ago
and Einstein quantum entanglement seemed
unsettling to indicate that something's
missing from our current understanding
of the quantum description of nature and
that paper elicited some thoughtful
responses including an especially
interesting one from Schrodinger and
Schrodinger put it this way he said the
best possible knowledge of a hole does
not necessarily include the best
possible knowledge of its parts so what
Schrodinger meant was that even if we
know as much as can possibly be known
about the state of our pair of qubits
one in Pasadena and one in Andromeda as
much as the laws of physics will allow
us to know I'm still helpless to predict
what I'll see when I open
the box in Pasadena or open it in
Andromeda and it was Schrodinger who
suggested that we used the word
entanglement to describe this unusual
quantum correlation and he added it is
rather discomforting that the theory
should allow a system to be steered or
piloted into one of the other type of
state at the experimenters mercy in
spite of his having no access to it well
shirting are meant by that is it seems
strange that it's up to me to decide by
either opening door number one or door
number two in Pasadena
whether I'll know what my friend will
find when he opens either door number
one or door number two and Andromeda but
Schrodinger understood well that these
correlations don't allow us to
instantaneously send a message from
Pasadena to Andromeda when my friend in
Andromeda opens his box through door
number one or door number two he just
observes a random bit irrespective of
what I did to my box in Pasadena so
there's no communication of information
from one box to the other nevertheless
there are unusual correlations between
the two qubits now this idea of quantum
entanglement didn't advance very much
for the next thirty years until the work
of John Bell in the 1960s and with Bell
we started to think about entanglement
in a somewhat different way not just as
something strange about quantum theory
but as a resource which we can use to
perform useful tasks they'll describe
games that two players can play the two
players Alice and Bob are cooperating
they're both trying to help each other
win the game and these games have the
following structure Alice and Bob each
receive inputs and they are to produce
outputs that are correlated in some way
that depends on the inputs that they
received and they're allowed to use
correlated bits that might have been
distributed to them before the game
began but under the rules of the game
they're not allowed to communicate
between when they receive their inputs
and when they produce
their outputs and for this particular
version of the game if Alice and Bob
play the best possible strategy then
averaged uniformly over the inputs that
they receive they can win with the
probability of at best seventy-five
percent but there's also a quantum
version of the game where the rules are
the same except that now Alice and Bob
are allowed to use entangled pairs of
qubits that were distributed before the
game began and using those qubits they
can play a better quantum strategy and
win the game with a higher probability
of success about 85% instead of 75% so
they've used the entanglement as a
resource to do something to win the game
with a higher success probability an
experimental physicists have been
playing the game for decades now and
winning with the higher probability of
success which Belle pointed out quantum
mechanics allows so these super-strong
correlations which are different from
the correlations and classical systems
quantum entanglement really do seem to
be part of nature's design Einstein
derided quantum entanglement he called
it spooky action at a distance which
sounds especially derisive when you say
it in German but nature is the way she
is as experiments reveal her to be and
we have to learn to love her as she is
so boxes are not like Sox's quantum
correlations are different than
classical correlations quantum
entanglement is something new you can
win a game with a probability of success
85% instead of 75% is that really a big
deal yeah yeah it's really a big deal
and you're gonna begin to appreciate why
it's a big deal if you think about
systems with more parts I mentioned a
book it's a hundred pages long if this
were a classical book written in bins
then every time you read another page
you'd learn another one percent of the
content of the book and after you've
read all 100 pages you'd know everything
that
in the book but now suppose it's a
quantum book written in qubits instead
of ordinary bits and the pages are
highly entangled with one another that
means when you look at the pages one at
a time you see only random gibberish you
get almost no information that
distinguishes one highly entangled book
from another and that's because the
information isn't written on the
individual pages the information in the
book is encoded almost entirely in how
the pages are correlated with one
another that's quantum entanglement and
what's interesting is that these
correlations are extremely complex so
that if I wanted to give you a complete
description of all the correlations
among a few hundred qubits if I wanted
to write down that in classical bits
then I would have to write down more
bits than the number of atoms in the
visible universe so it's never going to
be possible even in principle to write
that description down and that feature
was very intriguing to the physicist
Richard Feynman it led him to make this
suggestion in the 1980s that if we could
operate a computer which processes
qubits instead of bits then we ought to
be able to perform tasks that wouldn't
be possible with ordinary digital
computers what finally had in mind is
that if we can't even write down using
bids the state of a quantum computer
with a few hundred qubits then by
processing the qubits we ought to be
able to do things that an ordinary
digital computer would never be able to
emulate and when finally was making that
suggestion in the early 1980s there was
an undergraduate student at Caltech
studying mathematics named Peter shor
and like all Caltech undergraduates at
that time he was required to study
quantum physics as part of our core
curriculum and like many of our
undergraduates he retained what he
learned and some years later put it to
good use in making a remarkable
discovery an example of a problem which
we believe is hard for ordinary digital
computers is factoring finding prime
actors of a large composite integer and
what you're discovered is that with a
quantum computer factoring isn't a hard
problem it's not much harder than
multiplying two numbers together to find
their product and when I first heard
about this in 1994 I was really
awestruck because I realized what this
means is that the difference between
hard and easy problems between problems
that we'll be able to solve with
advanced technologies and problems that
will remain intractable even when we
have very advanced technologies that
boundary between hard and easy is
different in our world because it's a
quantum world then it would be if this
were a classical world and that was one
of the most interesting ideas I'd ever
heard in my life
now to give you an idea of what it means
an example of a factoring problem that
we can solve with existing technology is
factoring 193 digits that was done some
years ago now using a network of
workstations that collaborated over the
internet and it took a few months and
from what we know about how the
difficulty of the problem scales with
the number of bits we can estimate how
long it would take that same hardware to
factor a 500 digit number and it would
take longer than the age of the universe
so the difficulty of the problem scales
very unfavorably as we increase the
number of digits but suppose we had a
quantum computer and imagine that it has
the same clock speed as that classical
system it can perform the same number of
elementary operations on pairs of qubits
per second as this classical system can
perform elementary operations on bits so
you have to imagine that because we
don't have that now but if we did
factoring 193 digits could be done in
much less than a second in factoring 500
digits in just a couple of seconds so
the difficulty scales in a much
different way as we increase the number
of digits if we have a quantum computer
running Shor's algorithm now does
anybody care whether factoring is hard
problem or not yeah quite a few people
care about that
because the security of widely used
quantum Tsarina quantum widely used
public key cryptosystems
the security of those systems is based
on the presumed difficulty of factoring
and other related number theoretic tasks
when quantum computers are widely
available as they might be in a few
decades
then those protocols will become
vulnerable and will have to protect our
privacy in other ways there are
alternatives to using the current public
key systems but it's still not clear
what will be the best way to protect our
privacy in the coming post quantum world
well the broader lesson that we learn
from share is an algorithm and other
related algorithms is there's this
interesting classification of problems
there exists a family of problems which
are classically hard but quantumly easy
that quantum computers can solve an
ordinary digital computers can't solve
with reasonable resources and it's
important to understand better what are
the problems in that intermediate class
that are quantumly easy and classically
hard we've made some progress on that in
recent years but I think from a
physicists perspective what's most
important about quantum computing is
that we believe that we don't really
know this for sure that a quantum
computer would be able to efficiently
simulate any process that occurs in
nature that's not true for ordinary
digital computers which cannot simulate
very highly entangled quantum systems
with a quantum computer then we'd be
able to probe the properties of complex
molecules and exotic materials and also
study fundamental physics in new ways
for example by simulating high-energy
particle collisions or the quantum
physics of a black hole now there's a
lot of theoretical work being done on
quantum algorithms that could run on the
quantum computer but we don't have the
quantum computers yet so it's a little
bit frustrating sometimes my friend
Eddie far he wrote a Braille
paper not long ago about a new
application for quantum computers which
inspired me to send him this poem which
reads in part we're very sorry
at FRP your algorithms quantum can't run
it on those mean machines until we've
actually got and the poem goes on but
you get the idea we have lots of ideas
about what to do with the quantum
computer but we don't have one yet so
why is that well it's really really
really hard part of what makes it hard
is that we have to overcome a formidable
difficulty what we call decoherence
physicists like to envision a cat which
is both alive and dead at the same time
we're funny that way but we never in our
everyday lives see cats that are both
alive and dead at the same time they're
always completely alive or completely
dead
and we understand why that's true it's
because a real cat will interact with
its environments and those interactions
with the outside world
in effect measured the cat and projected
onto a state which is either completely
dead or completely alive that's
decoherence and that phenomenon of
decoherence is very important in helping
us to understand why even though quantum
physics holds sway in the microscopic
realm classical physics gives us a very
adequate description of most macroscopic
phenomena well a quantum computer -
though we may try hard to prevent it
from happening will interact with its
environment and those interactions will
in effect measure the quantum computer
and spoil the coherence of the
information it's processing which will
cause the quantum computer to fail so if
we expect to operate large-scale quantum
computers successfully we have to find a
way of fighting off the effects of
decoherence and other possible sources
of error errors are a problem even in
the classical world we all have bits
that we cherish everywhere it seems our
drag
lurking who delight and tampering with
those bids changing the color of our
balls as it were but in the classical
world we have learned how to fight off
those dragons if I have a classical bit
that I want to protect then I can store
some backup copies of the bit and the
dragon may come along and change the
color or one of the balls flip one of
the bits but I can employ a busy beaver
who frequently checks to see if the
three colors match and when they do not
the beaver repaints the mismatched color
so that all three match again so the
dragon hasn't had a chance to damage two
out of the three bits then the
information can be recovered
successfully because it's been redundant
li encoded and we would like to use that
same principle that redundant encoding
protects against there but use it for
quantum systems well it's not
immediately obvious how to make that
work as I've already emphasized we can't
copy unknown quantum states so we can
for example make a backup copy of the
quantum information in a quantum
computer in case the original gets
damaged and in the quantum world we have
to worry about more kinds of errors than
in the classical world it could be that
the dragon opens door number one of the
qubit and changes the color of the ball
and then reclose us the box
that would be like a bit flip error that
could occur to a classical bit but what
he might do instead is open door number
two of the box and change the color of
the ball and reclose the box that's what
we call a phase error which has no
classical analog and we have to be able
to protect both types of errors protect
against both types of errors without
knowing which kind might have occurred
there's another way of thinking about
the phase error which is we can imagine
that the dragon opens door number one of
the box and instead of flipping the
color of the ball just observes the
color and remembers it and that will
have the effect of changing the color of
the ball
we look through door number two and in
many physical settings it's easier to
remember the value of a bit than to flip
the bit and that makes the phase errors
particularly pervasive in many different
physical systems so really the key thing
is that if we want to operate a quantum
computer if we want to protect quantum
information we have to prevent any
information that's being processed from
leaking to the outside world we have two
perfectly seal off the information being
processed from the environment or else
the quantum computer will fail and that
sounds impossible because our Hardware
it's never going to be perfect well
we've learned in principle how to do it
by using quantum entanglement so if I
have one qubit that I would like to
protect I can encode that one qubit of
quantum information in a highly
entangled state of five cubits and then
the dragon might come along and damage
in some undetermined way one of the five
cubits but because the state is highly
entangled the information that's encoded
in that block of five qubits is not
accessible when you look at the qubits
one at a time just like we couldn't read
that hundred-page quantum book by
looking at the pages one at a time so
the interaction of the dragon with the
qubit doesn't necessarily have to damage
the encoded information and in fact we
can ask the beaver to come along and
make some carefully constructed
collective measurement on that block of
five qubits which will allow the beaver
to diagnose the damage that was done by
the dragon and reverse that damage and
the beaver too doesn't find out anything
about what the encoded state is which
would cause the encoded information to
class only learns about the errors and
can correct them what makes it work is
that the encoding is in a highly
entangled State so this idea of quantum
error correction is that if I want to
protect quantum information from the
environment I encoded in a highly
entangled state in a system with many
parts
and then the environment will typically
interact with those parts one at a time
and therefore not acquire any of the
information that's encoded and therefore
it not damage it and we've also learned
how to coherently process information
that's encoded in this highly entangled
form so we can imagine preparing an
encoded state of a CAD which is alive
and dead for at the same time and
maintaining that state for a very long
time and furthermore we know how to
coherently process the state of a large
quantum system suitably encoded so the
theorists are very excited about this
idea of quantum error correction it's
kind of a theory stream so we wrote
poems about it including my former
student Daniel goddess Minh he wrote a
sonnet of which I'll just quote one part
we cannot clone for force instead we
split coherence to protect it from that
wrong that would destroy our values
quantum bit and make our computation
take too long so it was just a theorists
dream twenty years ago but what's
exciting is that today quantum error
correction is starting to become serious
laboratory science and it's now being
carried out at places like Yale now in a
small scale but with great future
potential now one of the heroes of this
subject with quantum error correction is
my Caltech colleague Alexey kitaev the
day we met in 1997 was one of the most
exciting days of my scientific life when
I heard his seminar and made these notes
I felt I was hearing from Kataya ideas
about quantum error correction that are
potentially transformative the main
thing I learned was the connection
between quantum error correction and
topology mathematicians use the word
topology to mean the properties of an
object that from
variant if we smoothly deform the object
without ripping or tearing it and
likewise we would like the way a quantum
computer acts on its protected quantum
information to remain invariant as we
deform the computation by introducing
some noise so we'd like to use physical
interactions with a topological
character to do the processing and we
know of such topological interactions
and physics like the aharonov-bohm
effect in which the quantum state of an
electron is affected by transporting the
electron around tube of magnetic flux
even though the electron never directly
visits the region where the magnetic
field is nonzero and that change that a
Cochran apone phase that the electron
acquires remains the same if we deform
the trajectory of the electron all that
matters is the winding number of the
electron around the flux tube and these
types of topological interactions are
much richer in two dimensional systems I
can consider two dimensional media that
support an exotic type of particle and
we call an any on what happened here
this doesn't want to advance
okay and these particles have the
following property if I have a
two-dimensional medium that supports
many anions
there are many distinguishable quantum
states of that system of many anions
corresponding to different ways of
fusing together the individual particles
but all of those states look identical
when we examine them locally I can't
tell the difference between one state
and another and when I visit the ions
one at a time so that's just the type of
encoding of quantum information we want
to hide the information from the noise
in the environment and furthermore we
can process that information just by
exchanging the anions and so we can
imagine operating a topological quantum
computer which we could initialize by
creating pairs of any ions then process
information by performing a sequence of
exchanges on the anions so that their
worldlines and 2 plus 1 dimensional
space-time trace out a braid in
space-time and then I could read out the
information by bringing the onions
together pairwise to observe whether
they annihilate or not and disappear so
the beauty of this idea is that the
computation has an intrinsic resistance
to decoherence if I keep the temperature
low so there's no thermally excited and
ions diffusing around and I keep the
particles far apart from one another
except at the very beginning in the very
end then as long as we execute the right
braids we're guaranteed to get the right
answer in the quantum computation so
again that's the theorists dream I was
excited about this idea so I wrote a
poem about it
which reads in part alexei exhibits a
knack for persuading that some day will
crunch quantum data by braiding with
quantum states hidden where no one can
see protected from damage through
topology any on any on where do you roam
braid for a while before you go home and
there's more to the poem but you get the
idea we think it's an exciting dream but
is it just a dream well here too
technology is starting to catch up with
the theorists dream and one way of
realizing this idea uses another trick
that Kataya taught us that it's possible
to cut an electron into pieces that
sounds ridiculous an electron is an
indivisible elementary particle isn't it
but in a highly entangled world amazing
things can happen so an example of where
an electron can divide into pieces is in
one dimensional system a wire a quantum
wire a quantum wire can be
superconducting that means it can
conduct electricity without resistance
but there are two kinds of
superconducting wire and the ordinary
kind and the topological kind and at the
boundary between the two there sits an
object we call a my around a Fermi on
and so if I introduce an extra electron
into that segment of topological
superconductor and that electron can in
effect dissolve and disappear and in the
process the pair of my Arana fermions at
the two ends of the segment get excited
but that excitation can't be observed
locally when I look at the my Arana
fermions
one at a time it's really a collective
property of the two Meyer on a fermions
so that's an encoding of information
whether the electron was added or not
which is highly non-local and therefore
can be hidden from the environment now
there is highly suggestive experimental
evidence that this type of topological
encoding of information is possible in
quantum wires though more definitive
experiments still need to be done to
make this fully convincing
but it's very encouraging now I would
like to be able to process this type of
topologically encoded information by
exchanging particles when I'm limited to
a one dimensional wire the way I could
do that is by having T junctions in the
wires so that by controlling the
boundary between topological and
ordinary superconductors say with some
voltage gates I could park one of the my
Arana fermions around the corner move
the one on the right over to the left
and move the other one over to the right
in effect achieving an exchange of the
two particles that would be one step in
a protected topological quantum
computation that type of topological
processing of my honor fermions hasn't
yet been done experimentally but I'm
hopeful that it can be in the next
couple of years and that will be not
just a step towards a promising new
technology but also a milestone in basic
physics I don't want to give the
impression that this topological method
for encoding quantum information is the
only way to build quantum hardware there
are many ways that are being pursued in
different physical settings we can
imagine a qubit carried by a single atom
which could be either in its ground
state or some long-lived excited state
or we could have information encoded in
a single electron which has a spin or
magnetic moment which can be oriented
either up or down corresponding to this
two states of the qubit that's a
remarkable encoding because it's just
one electron carrying the information
and yet we've learned how to control
that electron spin accurately and
protected from decoherence for
reasonably long times or we could encode
the information as is done here in yale
in a ordinary superconducting circuit
one way to do that that's easy to
visualize is that we could have the
persistent current and a loop of
superconducting wire be either clockwise
or counterclockwise in practice that's
not really the right way to do it there
are more clever ways that work better
but it's a highly successful technology
for realizing qubits and it's really a
remarkable encoding because in this case
the qubit is encoded in the collective
motion of billions of electrons and yet
it behaves like a single qubit of
information like an atom or an electron
spin so I have an emphasis in
emphasizing three issues about quantum
computers which I've been thinking about
for a while one is why would we build
one what can we do with the quantum
computer and I think the best answer we
have is that with the quantum computer
we'd be able to simulate efficiently any
process that occurs in the quantum
system can we build one well now that we
understand the principles of quantum
error correction we're not aware of any
obstacles which has a matter of
principle will prevent us from realizing
large-scale quantum computers and how
will we build one what kind of quantum
hardware is the right kind to use well
as I've emphasized there are many
different approaches to building quantum
a hardware that are being pursued and
it's important that these be pursued in
parallel each one might find its own
technological niche or even a hybrid
technology that makes use of several
different types of hardware could turn
out to be important I felt for quite a
while that although this is already a
compelling research agenda that as our
ideas about quantum information
processing advanced we should expect
those ideas to connect to other problems
in physics and we're starting to see
that happen in recent years and a lot of
those connections have to do with what
we call the monogamy of entanglement
classical correlations are polyamorous
that means they can be shared in many
different ways so for example Adam and
Betty can both read the same newspaper
and that means they have the same
information and they become correlated
with one another but nothing prevents
Charlie from reading that newspaper -
and then he's just as strongly
correlated with Betty and with that
and Betty are with one another quantum
correlations are different they're
harder to share so that if any an atom
are very strongly entangled with one
another then Betty is used up all our
ability to entangle with Adam and Betty
and Adam can't be correlated with
Charlie at all and if on the other hand
Betty and Charlie are fully entangled
with one another then they can't be
correlated with Adam at all
that's the monogamy of entanglement and
the monogamy can be frustrating Betty
might want to attain goal with both Adam
and shortly but if she wants to get more
entangled with Charlie she can do so
only by sacrificing some of our
entanglement with Adam and then monogamy
has many different ramifications it's
important in cryptography because Adam
and Betty could try to use their
entangled state to generate a secret key
that can be used to encrypt and decrypt
a private message that they exchanged
and if they have a way of verifying that
their highly entangled with one another
then they can be assured that Charlie
won't be correlated with that key he
won't know their secret key so their
privacy will be protected
monogamy is important in the study of
quantum matter because if I have a
system of many particles many electrons
say each pair of electrons may want to
become entangled with one another but
each time an electron becomes more
entangled with one of its neighbors it
will have to be less entangled with
other neighbors so the electrons are
frustrated and they have to find some
optimal way of sharing their
entanglement which makes them as happy
as possible and that gives rise to
different phases of quantum matter in
which the entanglement is shared in
different ways and we're trying to
understand and classify those quantum
phases the monogamy is also important in
gravitational physics in particular in
the study of black holes in the next few
minutes I'd like to
explain that classically a black hole is
something from which nothing can escape
if astronaut is foolish enough as to
enter a black hole to cross its event
horizon she will never be able to return
to the outside or send a message to the
outside but quantumly is we've known for
40 years black holes can radiate they
emit Hawking radiation and eventually a
black hole will radiate away all of its
mass and disappear and that raises the
question of what happens to the
information that fell into the black
hole and was lost behind the horizon if
black holes are like other objects which
emit thermal radiation then we would
expect that information to be still
present to survive but to be very highly
scrambled to be encoded in a way that's
so scrambled that it would be very hard
to read and practice but in principle
the information still exists but black
holes are different from other objects
and the important respect that a black
hole has an event horizon and what that
means I've tried to depict in this
picture a space-time diagram with time
going up for it the geometry of a black
hole is so deform then it's possible to
draw a slice which I've shown here in
green which is really a space like slice
it's a slice of a single time and yet it
crosses both the collapsing body from
which the black hole form and nearly all
of the Hawking radiation that was
emitted while the black hole was
evaporating so if quantum information is
encoded in that collapsing body and it
is revealed in some form in the Hawking
radiation that means the same quantum
information is really in two places at
the same time in other words the
information has been copied but that's
cloning of quantum information which I
argued earlier is impossible so now
we're really stuck because we either
have to believe that information is
destroyed and give up on a central
tenant of quantum theory that evolution
is microscopically reversible or accept
the cloning occur
either way the foundations of quantum
theory would need revision well thinking
about this back in the 1990's and came
up with the idea called black hole
complementarity and the idea is that we
shouldn't think of the inside and the
outside of a black hole has two separate
subsystems of a single system instead
for reasons that aren't obvious in which
a theory of quantum gravity would have
to explain the correct view is that we
should think of the inside and the
outside as complementary ways of looking
at one and the same system one point of
view is appropriate for the observer who
stays outside the black hole the other
point of view is appropriate for the
observer who falls through the horizon
and enters the black hole interior but
because these are just two views of the
same quantum system there's no cloning
necessary for the information to be in
both the collapsing body and the
outgoing radiation and evidence
accumulated over some years thereafter
that this idea of black hole
complementarity is on the right track
but then I ran into trouble a few years
ago through the work of the group known
as ants black hole complementarity seeks
to reconcile three ideas each of which
on its own seems quite reasonable on the
one hand a black hole doesn't destroy
information but merely scrambles it up
puts it in a form which is difficult to
read on the other hand an observer who
fought whoops an observer who falls
through the horizon of a black hole
doesn't notice anything unusual at the
moment of horizon crossing at the moment
of entering the black hole don't later
on that observer will be crushed at the
singularity inside and third that an
observer who stays outside the black
hole doesn't see any unexpected
violations the usual rules of local
quantum physics an amps argued that
these three ideas can't all be
compatible that we have to give up at
least one of them
and they advocated that the conservative
resolution of the conflict is to give up
on to that instead of an observer being
able to pass through a black hole
horizon unscathed that observer would be
immediately destroyed right at the
moment of horizon crossing in a sealing
firewall that's a crazy claim because
it's not at all what we find when we
solve the gravitational field equations
to learn about the black hole geometry
so why would these smart people make
this crazy claim it's because of the
monogamy of entanglement because am
sorry you then if it's true that an
observer who falls through the black
hole arrives and doesn't notice anything
unusual at the moment of horizon
crossing and that means the black hole
radiation that's being emitted right now
has to be highly entangled with degrees
of freedom that are inside the black
hole on the other hand if information
really does get revealed as a black hole
evaporates and that means when the black
hole has been evaporated for a very long
time the Hawking radiation that's coming
out today should be highly entangled
with radiation that was emitted earlier
and if the rules of local quantum
physics are the usual ones outside the
horizon if it's going to be entangled
with SystemC after it's pulled away from
the black hole it has to already be
entangled with system seen when it's
very close to the horizon and now we
have a problem because system B just
outside the black hole wants to be
highly entangled both with the inside
and with the earlier radiation and it
can't have it both ways because of the
monogamy of entanglement and ants
proposed to relieve the tension by
breaking the entanglement between a and
B but that would mean that the black
hole horizon would be a highly energetic
place the firewall and we're still
really puzzled about this it exposed
that we don't understand very well what
the interior of a black hole is because
of subtle quantum effects and the main
reason I'm telling you about this is
that this observation might have been
made decades ago but it occurred
relatively recently because only in
the last few years have we grown
accustomed to thinking about other
problems in physics including
gravitational physics from the point of
view of entanglement dynamics and the
properties of quantum information so how
are we going to make progress on a
problem like this one how could how are
we going to understand what's inside a
black hole well our best hope is to
pursue the best idea we have about
quantum gravity which is the holographic
principle now this principle asserts
that contrary to naive expectations all
the information in a room like this
auditorium encoded in their brains and
our smartphones and so on can actually
be read on the boundary of the room the
floor and the walls and the ceiling but
it's encoded on the boundary in some
very very highly entangled form that's
extremely difficult to read in fact we
can think of the geometry of the room
who in the auditorium is sitting close
to other people as being encoded in the
quantum entanglement on the boundary so
it seems that it's really the
entanglement which determines how space
is held together which points are close
to other points a geometry according to
the holographic principle or so it now
seems is an emergent property of a very
highly entangled system and lives on the
boundary
we had a talk at Cal Tech last year by
Robert dygraf the director of the
Institute for Advanced Study and he was
reviewing theoretical physics and he
showed this slide which indicates how
the different ideas of theoretical
physics fit together and I thought it
was striking that he put quantum
information right in the center of
things he wouldn't have done that five
years earlier because it's only
relatively recently that the idea that
quantum information really is at the
core of the deepest questions and
physics has started to gain traction but
I would like to go further than diagraph
I would erase the theoretical from the
diagram because quantum information
really is an experimental science as
practiced it places like Yale and if
it's really true that we can think of
quantum geometry as an emergent feature
of very highly entangled systems and
that means that we ought to be able to
perform experiments on highly entangled
systems to gain insights into the
quantum properties of geometry so I
expect that in the coming decades at a
university like Yale on a tabletop in
the laboratory we'll be able to do
experiments with highly entangled
systems which will give us insights into
quantum gravity that would be very hard
to acquire without experimental guidance
so the way I like to think about quantum
information science is that we are at
the early stages of the exploration of a
new frontier of physics we might call it
the complexity frontier or entanglement
frontier this is different from the
short distance frontier we explore in
particle physics or the long distance
frontier of cosmology but like those
it's very fundamental and exciting we
are just now acquiring and perfecting
the tools to build and control very
precisely highly complex quantum systems
with many particles
systems that are highly entangled
systems that are so complex that we
can't simulate them with our digital
computers or very well predict how they
behave with our existing theoretical
tools and that's opening great
opportunities for new discoveries and
Yael is one of the institutions leading
advances at the entanglement frontier so
I'm especially glad to be here this week
at Cal Tech also we have an institute or
quantum information and matter dedicated
to exploring the entanglement frontier
an account tech we have a slogan a
tagline nature is subtle this is meant
to do homage to Einstein's famous
pronouncement subtle is the Lord but
malicious he is not but the fact is
despite all his genius Einstein was
under estimating the subtlety of nature
when he dismissed quantum entanglement
as spooky action at a distance and our
aim in quantum information science now
is to explore and joy exploit the
subtlety of the quantum world in all its
many facets and ramifications so thanks
for listening to me today and then
tomorrow's lecture I hope I'll see many
of you well I'll discuss in greater
depth the connections between quantum
information and gravitation Thanks
so we have time for a few questions yes
I mean there are none quantum things
like photographic storage of information
based on waves and interference in the
heavens any of the same properties or
these error correction it's a really
entanglement because even with those
holographic classical and coatings of
information if you look at a small part
of a hologram it certainly doesn't allow
you to reconstruct the whole picture but
it does give you some significant
information about the image that's
holographically store these entangling
coatings aren't like that you can look
at a big hunk of the quantum memory and
still know almost nothing about the
encoded state
the question is how do you measure the
entanglement and the answer is it's not
an easy thing to measure and if I have
many identically prepared copies of the
system then I can make measurements make
different measurements on different
copies and thereby reconstruct enough
about the quantum state to determine the
entanglement but in general it's not a
very easy thing to measure there are
actually some some neat ideas about how
you can measure quantities related to
entanglement that tell you about the
global properties of quantum
correlations but they won't really give
you exactly the well I didn't even say
how to quantify entanglement I'll talk
about that a little bit more there is a
way to do it you can quantify
entanglement essentially by asking how
much information is missing if you look
at Part A of the system and that means
you're learning about what an observer
who's confined to Part A can find out
and that observer is going to be missing
some of the information in Part A
because it's correlated with Part B and
so one way to do it is that many copies
make different measurements in Part A
and Part B but in the single copy case
it's hard
any large system in nature using a
quantum computer better than we can do
with a classical one so is the value-add
entirely from the faculty to do more
computations at a time and it's much
faster or are there any types of
computations so that the question is
where does the advantage of the quantum
computer really come from and the
question was framed as is it coming from
the fact that you can do many
computation simultaneously this is
actually a pretty subtle question so I
was so little that was a bit cagey in
not putting it exactly the way you did
although you'll often hear people
describe the advantage of a quantum
computer that way it is true that if we
consider a superposition of many
classical states we can run the
computation once and only once and to
simulate with a classical computer what
that computation does it seems like we
would have to run the classical
computation many times but the reason I
don't like putting it quite that way is
it's a little bit misleading because in
the end you're going to have to read
something out to get the result of the
computation and you're quite limited in
the information you can extract in that
final measurement so the power really
comes from designing your quantum
algorithm in a sufficiently clever way
that those different parts of the
computation interfere with one another
constructively on the right answer and
that's why it's really an art to
designing quantum algorithms that have
advantages over classical algorithms and
why in many cases we don't think
profound quantum speedups of the
computational problem are possible they
didn't say this but for the hardest
types of problems that classical
computers can solve or we can check the
answer efficiently the problems you know
we call np-complete quantum computers
can speed those up a little bit but not
nearly as profoundly as they speed up
problems like factoring so the problem
has to be pretty well matched to these
special capabilities of a quantum
computer for a very big speed-up to be
possible
I couldn't hear you and starts when you
observe those superimposed two-qubit you
collapse it into one of two states
always it's always one or two and that's
no it could be one of many couldn't
imagine using boolean logic when you're
in people are talking about the sorts of
things like you youyou said that the
things are constantly easy surround the
things that are classically easy but
I've always kind of thought it was being
really separate domains of computation
so the question is why did I draw that
diagram classically easy with quantum
wheezy of being a larger containing set
aren't they really completely separate
things well what I meant by that is that
in principle if you had a very well
controlled quantum computer you could
use it to do a classical computation
it's pretty easy in principle to get a
quantum computer to simulate a classical
computer and therefore solve any problem
the classical computer can solve it's
hard to do it the other way to get a
classical computer to simulate a quantum
computer of course it would be kind of a
stupid thing nowadays to give you the
your classical problem to a quantum
computer maybe someday
quantum computers will be so advanced
that it won't be so foolish but that was
all I meant that a quantum computer at
least conceptually can easily simulate a
classical one
np-complete we believe is outside quorum
easy but there are also problems that
are in quantum easy which are not an NP
at all in other words it's not
necessarily the case that a problem that
can be solved quickly by a quantum
computer can we can easily verify the
answer with the classical computer and
many of the quantum simulation problems
have that feature